[Musique]
salut à vous peuple d internet c'est
assez drôle parce que je suis en train
de finir cette vidéo et le montage très
très tard et je peux rajouter ça avant
alors que la vidéo qui va suivre a été
tourné à 8 heures du matin
c'est beaucoup trop tôt j'ai rencontré
au mois de mai lors d'une émission de
radio le champion de france de mémoire
et je l'invité sur la chaîne pour voir
les techniques qu'ils utilisent et faire
le cobaye
on avait pris comme thème les pays les
capitales qui sont des choses qui
servent toute la vie forcément
et juste avant de commencer une petite
annonce très rapide il ya quelques jours
est sorti notre jeu avec céline h qui
s'appelle menteur menteur c'est un jeu
qui est basé sur le bluff mais ça vous
en saurez plus ce vendredi puisque on
s'est fait une petite partie des
familles avec max beurre delà du mini
dock seven etc
mais là c'est surtout pour vous dire que
depuis dix jours j'ai lancé une boutique
en ligne sur www.facebook.com où vous
pouvez retrouver mon livre c'est
possible de le dédicacer il ya aussi des
livres des copains du tattoo de doc
seven de max bird ya aussi mon jeu il ya
aussi le tee shirt que j'ai créée qui
permet de mentalité des gens il ya des
places de spectacle olympien on est à
presque 25 % je crois de remplissage
c'est ouf c'est génial je suis très très
touché que vous réserviez si longtemps à
l avance et les bonnes places comme on
souffre un point à être prises c'est
cool si vous l'avez pas fait réserver ya
un lien dans la description
bon c'est pas juste pour vous parler de
la boutique comme ça c'est surtout que
j'ai créé des pâtes qui sont valables
jusqu'à noël ou par exemple si tu prends
le t-shirt plus le jeu ou ou le tilt ou
le jeu plus le livre par exemple
enfin des packs comme ça ou quand tu
prends plusieurs choses ça fait 15 % de
réduction par rapport au prix de vente
normal et petit bonus pour la fin il ya
un cadeau avec chaque commande et dans
les spas qui a deux cadeaux et dans
l'écran pas qui a trois cadeaux c'est
sûr www.flickr.com schumi lire dans la
description vous checkez si vous avez
envie et sinon bonne vidéo et ça fait
plaisir chat salut bonjour comment allez
vous moi ça va merci de m'avoir posé la
question il ya quelque chose que j'ai
jamais fait l'effort de faire c'est
d'apprendre les capitales et les pays le
plus tôt vous faire appel à un pote qui
est en bas juste champion de france de
mémoire monsieur sébastien martinez donc
ça fait quelques temps qu'on se connaît
comment ces rencontres vont se
rencontrer à la radio en duplex leur
duplex vous ap alex et moi j'étais à
paris c'est safran sont claires
voilà je crois me rappeler le lendemain
pour refaire un duplex s'était contenté
de dire c'est qu'ils se revoient chaque
fois qu'on est il vaut mieux alors je me
disais à peu près la même chose
alors en plus de salles avantage c'est
que je les connais vraiment pas mais
capital jamais fait cet effort là donc
je vais les apprendre en même temps que
vous et si vous avez des questions vous
me le dites dans les commentaires et je
le répèterai ne fait pas ça parce que
c'est pas en même temps
arrête de croire tout ce que tu vois sur
youtube toile et déjà l'on prétend qu'on
fait cet exercice il faut se tester vous
vérifiez si on connaît déjà
c'est vrai parce que s'il n'a pas de
sens de réapprendre justement connaît
déjà
ça c'est un peu la limite toujours avec
les stratégies de mémorisation faisons
d'avoir une photo de ce qui m a gagné
plein de chaunac mais on connaît tous on
se teste comme ça une fois qu'on s'est
testé après on prend coller capital
qu'on reconnaît au quart temps qu'on est
bien dans la liste mais on commence par
l'autriche et la autriche
ça doit autriche ça va autriche par le
prince igor pour mémoriser voiture
explique tout le temps s'est créé du
lien créé du lien est-ce que tu
maîtrises déjà donc là on va jouer avec
des associations et bien sûr chaque
chaque personne va peut-être avoir des
associations différents l' autriche tu
penses à quoi je pense à une autruche
presque autant je le connais pas sa
capitale autant je connais sa forme
parce que j'ai tout un système que tu
dois avoir aussi pour pour connaître les
reformuler de tennis et ça donc une
autruche et notre chien donc la capitale
donc après on à vienne elles viennent
qu'est-ce que ça t'inspire ça m'inspire
de l'eau de l'eau déjà
puisque pourquoi pourquoi loup
d'ailleurs qu'en fait j'ai longtemps
confondu vienne et venise ok super est
là c'est pour ça c'est génial faits de
lot de joies de l'eau comme ça donc je
vois de l'eau je vois des maisons dans
l'eau etc
en fait je vois venise moi quand je
pense à liège génial on va jouer avec ça
alors imagine donc donc de l'eau c'est
cette venise où pierre et maintenant il
ya plus une fois qu'on a deux
associations donc deux nations qui sont
propres
tu crées une score une connexion donc
une autruche et venise qu'est-ce qu'on
peut même manger notre jeu qui court
tellement vite qu'elle ne s'enfonce pas
dans l'eau elle peut courir sur l'eau
mon patelin ouais donc elle court comme
ça et voilà
elle court et là il ya tous les
bâtiments de qui la regarde son nez sur
menu c'est vrai elles courent courent
courent il est super et et en plus de ça
ça lui permet de venir jusqu'à moi
l'autre jusqu'à un peu moins grand très
bien donc bulgare et ça t'inspire quoi
bulgari et bulgari plus le gars ça me
fait penser à cigares 6pm ok souvenirs
hakim parle qui me parle de yaourt
bulgare a alors pas du tout c'est ma
réponse assez naturelle pendant l'été
pour vous donc toi tu veux ni un cigare
ouais super donc c'est sofia la capitale
qu'est ce que ça t'inspire le mot sofia
on vous a entendu ses malheurs de sophie
ou tu les as vus et cela dit personne
n'a ça me ferait plutôt penser à un sofa
dans ce quart à sow souffre un parfait
sauf à y en a qui me disent qu'ils
connaissent une sophie si vous
connaissez une sophie entz au figaro
moment une photo complice associés ton
image
écoute moi je vais m j'aime être une
sophie virtuel ok sur un sofa sauf un en
train de fumer un cigare et ça fait des
bulles comme ça juste images et voilà ce
gros cigare terrance aussi
régler et b2 gold comme geste dans le
bundle
c'est ça alors ça j'ai c'est que
j'insiste sur l'essence parce que le
plus important c'est duty un maximum de
cinq sens on parle de synesthésie bien
sûr on a une information visuelle qui
nous arrive on à unir célèbre hacker
sollicité quand c'est auditifs c'est une
autre hervé chaque sens et connectée
lunaire et donc facilement on peut
imaginer que si on utilise des cinq sens
synesthésie on va plus facilement
derrière à plus de récupérer les
chiffres tu connais chiffres très bien
contre chypre tu penses à à des chips
les chips super nicosie maintenant bat
nicolas mois jusqu'au lancé nicolas mme
à nicolas tard nicolas dans ta zik
imputée à nicolas écoutez je vais vous
dire l'ancien président que ça me va
très bien michael moore président donc
chips ni l'ancien président nicolas
parce qu'en plus nicolas sarkozy ça fait
nicosie tu vasculaire c'est parfait ah
oui la musique mais qui se gavent de
chips away sans problème éthique tramway
est potes si j'ai le goût ces chiffres
le goût de l'amertume
on continue on a après danemark
ça t'inspire quoi danemark samassa me
fait penser à des kiwis des kiwis mais à
cause d'un vieux forçage psychologique
qui qui qui fait passer par un demain
définir pas kiwi éléphants ok ok
copenhague copenhague
si darren julien spontanément c'est a
pas de lien logique non en anjou
médialogie nous focaliser sonorités coop
juste une moule à 60 g ouais voici une
coupe avec des algues dans d'accord coop
moi j'avais plus partie sur un flic un
flic à la coop accueilleront une vague
un flic américain sur exactement
bah du coup il a jonglé en veux pas
gillard compliqué et tu vois les isole
faire il plus qu'un même si bien sûr et
donc même tu peux nous faut qu'ils
disent ici gamelle comme ça ils tombent
dans l'eau exactement c'est marrant
ça me va des pays baltes estonie
lettonie
le tigre est antoine aminés en 1981 toi
même tu sais donc estonie tallinn
qu'est-ce que ça t'inspire
c'est quoi paul tallinn tallinn malinké
ça m'arrive à moi mais je vous regarde
pas trop tel talent inné tallinn -
changerait une lettre tu vas genre
imagine parfait mais il faut juste que
je que j'intègre ce changement 7,7 l
enfance l estonie donc ton france 10 la
moyenne sont inexacts c'est pas dur il
essaye de l'attraper pour la manger il
est là il en train de
oui parce qu'elles font abeilles elle se
fout de sa gueule en plus sert qu'à
chaque fois qu'ils se mêlent l'attraper
et s'envola dans la magie ce test est ça
me paraît pas mal parce que l'important
aussi c'est que vous comprenez bien la
mécanique nous amène sébastien csssae en
fête au son ça fait partie de la
mécanique
une fois qu'on a terminé ces
associations il faut en général c'est ce
que je fais au bout de 5 10 en fonction
de la vitesse on se re test pour
vérifier pour alors chypre ce sont les
chips 6-1 nicolas sarkozy à savoir
nicosie ce nicosie supects tout à fait
donc après si je la connaissais vraiment
pas de bulgarie
bulgarie alors c'était plus dur mais du
coup je suis sur mon sofa en train de
fumer des cigares au bubble gum qui font
des bulles avec sophie sofcap sofia
autriche
l'autriche mon management ne truche qui
vient vers moi dans venise donc vienne
estonie avec ma petite tajine qui
s'envolent qu'il n'arrive pas à voir
mais elle semble parce qu'elle a des
ailes donc c'est aline et le danemark
alors tu vois ça c'est le kiwi
heureusement que j'ai gardé le kiwi qui
se sert à ça d'où l'importance de bien
se faire confiance sur sa première image
parce que danemark ça ne disait rien du
tout et je me sui bat par kiwi bah oui
donc c'est que guillon va être quand on
sait que jude l'extérieur tu dis mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ça il est tant
mieux en fait si vu de l'extérieur c'est
qu'est ce qu'il raconte c'est que c'est
la bonne association parce que souvent
c'est très spontanée bien plus ce sera
spontané mais c'est j'aurais j'aurais
pris la danette pour le coup les trucs
comme ça je n'aurais pas dû jouer donc
j'ai mon flic sur la vague un peu dingue
donc ouais y est au foot et je pense que
peut être vous aussi vous l'avez fait en
même temps donc là on l'a fait on a fait
l'exemple pour ça qu'on a vraiment pris
le temps mais je pense que vous avez
bien compris ce qui a amené sébastien là
dessus toi quel rythme après toi de
révision de ce genre de choses sur leurs
conseils qu'il faut c'est au début de
faire souvent donc la même dès qu'on
affine refaire donc dans la journée leur
faire quasiment deux fois de suite après
et presque le soir avant de se coucher
dans l'est dans la semaine le faire une
fois et après de toute façon si on
apprend des informations comme ça sont
cohérentes dans la vie de tous les jours
que vous allez revoir en fait dans les
lectures vous a tant parlé donc tu vas
l'encoder en fait naturel nasa et qu'on
fait ce sont surtout les passer le cap
de la première semaine mais ça c'est le
plus important
je viens je t'invite à revenir quand tu
veux et dans ce monde des petits sujets
comme ça vous pouvez nous dire ce que
vous aimeriez
qu'on fasse avec sébastien ce dont on
pourrait parler mais ce mec est juste
très très passionnant donc profitons
gens de l'avoir à notre disposition
n'est ce pas je recommande dans livre
une mémoire infaillible qui vient de
sortir en grand format prenez suis là
parce qu'il ya un cahier d'exercices il
est beaucoup plus sympathique je vous
mets le lien dans la description et je
mets un lien vers sa chaîne youtube
aventure on a les bons ingrédients
c'est fun d'affreux oui j'ai des
discussions que j'ai eu pas mal de fois
avec vous quand vous le dit ouais mais
ça se prend vachement plus de temps oui
mais en fait c'est juste pour tu leur
tiennent vraiment où est il ya deux
aspects plus de temps ça dépend sur quel
échelle de temps à réfléchir les
circuits réfléchi sur cinq minutes
évidemment c'est pas si cette
association tu vas perdre ton temps par
contre si tu réfléchis sur une semaine
tu va avoir besoin de beaucoup moins de
consolidation entre est donc derrière tu
gagnes déjà du temps exactement en fait
on ne peut pas apprendre si on s'amuse
pas même dans le travail si on fait pas
quelque chose qui nous plaît bien ça
sent du coup les gens sinon t'es même
pas regardé les vidéos si je me faisais
chier en faire c'est la même merci
beaucoup c'est d'aller visiter sa chaîne
pensez à regarder pour son livre et
penser à liker à vous abonner comme
d'habitude très bientôt chao est ce que
tu as une astuce sébastien pour qu'ils
n'oublient pas d'appuyer sur les deux
roues là qu'ils sont entrain d'appareils
une question du coup le mieux c'est
qu'ils fassent des moyens on fait ce
genre de suite adoré d'oublier en fait
si tu fais pas de suite ou à laisser un
champion de mémoire qui vient de te dire
ça
[Musique]